um and it yesterday on Capitol Hill they
had a big hearing about it and it's you
know it's not just the people coming
across the border but it's the finol one
of the parents there talked passionately
about how she lost her daughter because
of the finol let's take a look in my
humble opinion Mr mayor's border
policies is partially responsible for my
daughter's
death his wide open border policy allows
Mass massive quantities of poisonous
venal into our country my family is
broken my heart is broken and he
couldn't even be here to face me
today whatever he's doing that is more
important than facing me
today I don't know what that could be um
so may orcus didn't show up during his
own impeachment hearing uh so he would
didn't have a chance to hear that so uh
I don't I don't know if they have the
votes to impeach him I don't I believe
it's got to go through the Senate after
the house to to you could just impeach
him simply in the house the trial would
be in the Senate but they have the votes
I think probably to impeach him it it
would work just like uh it does for the
president where you've got to be found
guilty by the house of high crimes and
misdemeanors and Democrats say what's
the high crime or misdemeanor you might
have a policy dis uh you know uh
discussion over things we don't like
what Joe Biden is installed on his
Southern border but you can't impeach
somebody over that the Democrats say but
Republicans say look it's it's a
disaster out there he's told different
stories that are not true he's got to go
and Brian you're absolutely right the
Republicans who the speaker is Holding
On by a thread to his job and in fact
the only way they got that stop Gap
spending Bill across the border rather
across the Finish Line yesterday was a
whole bunch of Democrats voted
because a whole bunch of Republicans
including Elise stonic and Jim Jordan
both voted against the speaker
Republicans that the the impeachment
process is a political process not a
criminal trial um and there's a lot of
moderates especially Democrats that are
seeing just like we're seeing that
immigration is suddenly becoming the top
issue they may want to impeach too it's
not just Republicans anymore Democrats
are seeing what's going on and y'all if
you're a parent this could be any of our
child I don't want to sit in of Congress
and have to lose the the thing I love
the most other than Jesus Christ is my
child and for these women to hear their
stories that just that's heart-wrenching
you spend so much time and energy
raising your children to make this world
a better place you love them more than
anything in the world everything you do
is for that child and for an illegal
immigrant to come into our country and
this mom talked yesterday Tammy Nobles
her daughter Kayla just turned 20 she
just raised her child she was looking
forward to to Kayla getting married to
walking down the aisle one day to
helping her pick out a house one day and
have children and grandkids one day for
her and Tammy talked here she is and she
said her daughter was in her house in
her room and a thir an MS13 gang member
here legally went into her child's room
strangled her with a cord but before
that brutally raped her her little girl
that's not right she just been 20 for a
few days she said I think three days her
life was taken from her that Mom will
never be the same so you this hits home
it does could happen to anyone I'm Steve
duy I'm Brian killme and I'm Angy aart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis